oh professor quick question i feel like
my marriage is falling apart
should i keep trying to fix it don't
stop
even if you think something is
fundamentally broken i mean i don't
think something is
fundamentally broken necessarily you
know something is fundamentally broken
is it because i'm not present enough
when i'm at home or because i spend too
much time writing catalan fanfic
two very different problems right and
the
the latter one you can really only
figure out
by instinct if anything i feel like i
should be spending more time working on
the fan fiction you might think that you
do
but you don't i baked her a cake on her
birthday but
the middle didn't rise and it came out
horribly middles are hard
right i mean our stormlight role-playing
really sparked things up for a while but
my subconscious is terrified about the
fact that i don't know where this is
going
and i feel like i should so i'm a fraud
you can't be so hard on yourself
it was good advice
you